[Music]
on this Tuesday night the race to rescue
survivors in turkey and Syria
and the despair in the destruction
please do not forget us
turkeys please for Aid and the reaction
to Canada's contribution Motorsports
very strong but we do need more help
plus what Canada's premiers think of
ottawa's offer of billions in health
care funding we're a little disappointed
the glass is half full
foreign
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
there's news about funding for health
care in Canada we will get to that in
just a moment but we begin with the
desperate efforts to save lives in
turkey and Syria after the devastating
earthquakes on Monday
in places it looks apocalyptic this
mountain of rubble used to be an
apartment building in idlib Syria it
collapsed while people slept
anguish is everywhere the death toll
Rising every hour as more bodies are
found there are some flashes of Hope
I thought it was gonna happen in Syria a
newborn baby was pulled from the rubble
she's safe in a hospital now it's
believed her mother died just after
giving birth and she is the only one of
her family who survived the quake and if
there is one image that encompasses the
despair it is this father holding the
hand of his fifteen-year-old daughter
who died in her bed buried beneath slabs
of concrete
in turkey and Syria it's now believed
more than seven thousand people have
died thousands of others are injured and
layered on top of the disaster is cold
wintry weather and the knowledge time is
running out to find survivors Redmond
Shannon has our top story tonight
urgently removing Rubble one fistful at
a time
little newer learns her father is here
a smile of recognition after more than
24 hours trapped
in Syria and turkey Rescuers are racing
Against Time and the elements
the bitter winter cold and the dread
brought on by more aftershocks some of
those trapped are reportedly still
sending voice notes to loved ones from
the rubble it was such an awful
experience
in my life Jalal Youssef and his family
had to leave their damaged home to take
refuge in a school my entire family is
here including my grandparents my
grandmother is a woman like a disabled
woman she needs a special care there are
I think more than
1 000 people in this school
each class has at least more than 60
people in many places vital
infrastructure has been wiped out like
this hospital I'm devastated I see
bodies inside everywhere
although I'm used to seeing buddies
because of my uh
expertise it's it's very difficult also
for me in more remote communities
frustration is rising as survivors and
their loved ones wait anxiously for
heavy equipment to arrive Murat alinax
relatives are still missing
not a single person is here he says we
are without a home without anything what
shall I do where can I go turkey's
president estimates 15 of the country's
85 million people has been affected in
some way in Syria desperation touches
everything please do not forget us
um we have nothing nothing here we need
medicines we need food we need fuel we
need doctors we need nurses we just need
every everything because of the Civil
War much of Northwest Syria relies on
Aid coming across the border from Turkey
where authorities and those once
supplying that Aid are now overwhelmed
imagine that we are we are working with
our own hands to to find to to pull out
the people under under the the rebels
Mohammed hamza's fear is that syrians in
need will be forgotten simply because it
might be easier for the world to help
turkey Redmond Shannon double news
London
laughs
Syria's civil defense team also known as
the white helmets posted this video
today calling it a true miracle
one child is carried out then another it
says an entire family was rescued from
under the rubble of their house in a
Syrian Village
and the sounds of the crowd are sounds
of joy
[Applause]
turkey's President says he wants to
ensure rescue work is carried out
quickly he's declared a three-month
state of emergency and 10 of turkey's 81
provinces that are hardest hit by the
earthquakes the World Health
Organization warns 23 million people may
be affected by the disaster in turkey
and Syria we've reached journalists in
two Turkish cities that were hardest hit
Melda Doan is in Adana where thousands
remain out in the cold we'll hear from
her in a moment Melinda nusafora is in
the city near the epicenter of the
second quake
Donna some of the things that we've been
seeing as we're traveling through
karaman Mirage almost just seem too
unbelievable to be real this size and
the scope of the destruction
just is hard to comprehend our teams
have seen piles of rubble that look
almost like piles of sand and you can't
believe that that was once an apartment
building it's hard to believe that there
could still be people trapped under
Rubble like that not just here in
karaman Mirage but in 10 provinces right
across turkey and into Syria as well one
of the biggest challenges has been the
weather huge snowstorms on Monday night
delayed relief workers reaching this
region by up to 18 hours that's
according to turkey's interior Minister
it's been a blue sky day today which
means they've been able to really get a
lot of the search and rescue underway
but it is a freezing night tonight
temperatures well below zero
no electricity very limited phone and
internet access and that is making it
incredibly difficult for teams to
coordinate to communicate with each
other and even to know just how many
people are still trapped underneath
those buildings and are unaccounted for
I mean I don't know in southeast and
turkey in one of the 10 cities the
husband hit by the devastating
earthquake in the country now what
you're seeing behind me was a 14-story
building but after the earthquake on
Monday 4 a.m this building has flattened
totally as you can see now rescue
workers are trying since the first hours
of the earthquake trying to find anyone
who is still surviving anyone who's
still alive under the rubbles
but unfortunately only five people made
it alive hopes are really low at this
moment everyone in the region has to
sleep outside in shelters we know that
380 000 people have slept in shelters uh
it's gonna be a tough night but uh we
hope for the best that we might maybe uh
find anyone who could be alive in this
building behind me and all over the
country as the death soul is increasing
every hour
that is freelance reporter Imelda Doan
and Adana Turkey getting search and
rescue teams to where they're needed is
a massive Logistics challenge a number
of countries are sending them rooting
them through the airport in Istanbul
Jackson prosco is also there on route to
the earthquake zone Jackson
Donna Istanbul's airport has become the
Hub of this International Rescue and
Recovery Mission what you see behind me
are ordinary Turkish citizens many of
them who normally work in the tourist
trade they're coming here because they
think they can lend a hand to the
International Rescue workers who are now
coming in so you're seeing drivers and
translators people who would normally
work with tourists in the area preparing
to help save their fellow countrymen and
we are seeing Aid workers from around
the world descend here on this airport
this is where they're Landing they're
collecting their gear and they're
preparing to head out into the hardest
hit areas we know that crews are coming
from every corner of the globe this has
been a rapid International response to a
devastating tragedy and so that explains
the Frantic Pace that we're seeing here
at the airport we have quite literally
seen people sprinting through the
airport with boxes of relief supplies
and people who are search and rescue
workers in their hard helmets and with
their gear running through the airport
coming together getting their briefings
before they can head out to those hard
hit areas all right Jonathan prosco in
Istanbul thanks
the Canadian government isn't sending
search and rescue teams at this point
but it has committed to financial help
prime minister Justin Trudeau announced
Canada will provide 10 million dollars
in immediate aid to the people of turkey
and Syria the government says other
options are being looked at Mike doorlay
explains why immediate help is critical
to saving lives
sifting through flattened buildings is a
slow painstaking Endeavor a rescuing
survivors takes finesse in major
resources
The Staggering loss of human life is
taking a toll on survivors many of whom
have nowhere to go and people are afraid
for aftershocks or new shocks and
therefore they they've gone outside and
some have
visited their friends in in tents so
that they're less vulnerable the Turkish
government says they've received offers
of help from at least 70 countries so
far German rescue teams are now on the
ground the UK has promised to send
theirs even Ukraine is sending a large
Team Canada has donated 10 million
dollars but is still assessing the need
for boots on the ground we're also
looking at various other options or
Medical Teams heavier Urban search and
rescue and I know that also Minister not
is looking at options for the dart as
well speaking with global news turkey's
ambassador to Canada emphasize how they
need help now I mean we would wish more
to be done by everyone because this is a
humanitarian issue but I'm not in a
position to tell what Canada should give
or should not give the money he says is
appreciated but with over 6 000
flattened buildings he couldn't hide the
fact he expected more Canada's uh in
support model sport very strong the
governor general prime minister Party
leaders the support is really uh very
heartwarming
and diplomacy aside heartwarming won't
save lives Mike trolley Global News
Toronto
eight organizations are springing into
action to help for Canadians looking to
contribute the humanitarian Coalition as
a place to turn it brings together
leading Aid organizations including
Oxfam Canada you can go to their website
together.ca or call 1-855-461-2154
the Prime Minister pitches his health
care funding plan to Canada's premiers
coming up what he's offering and how
it's being received
Canada's premiers say some money is
better than no money but they are not
thrilled by the offer of billions of
dollars in health care funding from the
Prime Minister it's 196 billion over 10
years but the premieres say considering
150 billion of that was already budgeted
for the provinces and territories it
amounts to 46 billion in new money
that's not nothing they say but it's not
enough our chief political correspondent
David Aiken is with me to dissect all of
this David well Donna the Trudeau
government thought that 46 billion
dollars in new cash over 10 years would
be enough that pot of new money includes
an extra 19 billion dollars over 10
years for the Canada Health transfer
that would be extra money that it is
hoped will help with immediate pressures
in pediatric hospitals emergency rooms
and with long wait times for surgeries
the new money also includes 25 billion
dollars over 10 years for one-on-one
deals with individual provinces now
provinces can decide how to spend their
share but Ottawa wants it spent on one
or more of the following areas improving
access to family doctors hiring more
health workers providing Mental Health
Services or modernizing the health
system separately an additional two
billion dollars is being set aside for
indigenous Health priorities and the
FEDS will also set aside 1.7 billion
dollars that can be used to boost wages
of personal support workers I have high
expectations but also reasonable
expectations that in the coming weeks
not months we will conclude bilateral
agreements begin flowing more money and
Canadians will start seeing Real Results
David the premiers were quick to say
they expected more how much do they want
well Donna as part of that 46 billion
over 10-year package the federal
government had put on the table the feds
were prepared to give the provinces
about 4.9 billion dollars in new funds
next year the provinces though wanted 35
billion dollars next year alone if it
significantly less than what we were
looking for in terms of you know the
Baseline funding injection into the
Canada Health transfer the premiers will
now meet among themselves likely within
days and we just saw this two hours ago
this proposal and so it's very difficult
to digest it in full so we will take it
away and see what it means within each
of our jurisdictions now Ottawa is also
insisting on certain conditions the
provinces would have to meet in order to
get this new funding and so far there
doesn't seem to be much argument from
The Province it's not even Quebec and
that's because the feds and the
provinces share the same spending
priorities it's just that the provinces
want the federal government to spend
more Donna all right David Aiken in
Ottawa thanks
deadly disaster ahead the aftermath of a
landslide in southern Peru
people were screaming to run for safety
in southern Peru as a landslide swept
through this town tearing down almost
everything in its path and leaving
masses of debris in its wake days of
torrential downpours led to the
landslide and the rain is expected to
continue in the region at least 15
deaths have been confirmed there are
fears that number could rise well above
40 as the search for dozens of missing
people continues in the United Kingdom a
former metropolitan police officer has
been jailed for at least 30 years for
sexually assaulting a dozen women David
Carrick who joined the police force in
2001 admitted last month to being a
serial rapist a 48-year-old pleaded
guilty to 49 offenses including 24
counts of rape along with charges of
assault attempted rape and false
imprisonment the crimes took place from
2003 to 2020.
Ukraine claims Russia has endured its
deadliest day of the war country's Armed
Forces claims more than one thousand
Russian troops were killed over the last
24 hours that number has not been
independently verified Russia also
claims to have killed large numbers of
Ukrainian troops in recent weeks U.S
Navy has released new images of the
retrieval of remnants of that suspected
Chinese spy balloon shot down by an
American fighter jet on Saturday the
photo shows Sailors pulling parts of the
High Altitude surveillance balloon from
Waters off the coast of Myrtle Beach in
South Carolina governments in the U.S in
Canada say the balloon was being used to
spy on sensitive military sites the
Chinese government claims it was a
weather research balloon that was blown
off course the recovered material will
be taken to a lab to be analyzed by the
FBI
next how we respond to disasters can
help restore our faith in humanity
[Music]
the world is watching the devastating
aftermath in turkey and Syria and to
give you a sense of the severity of the
earthquakes here are some before and
after images this castle built almost 2
000 years ago has stood watch over the
Turkish city of gaziantep ever since it
crumbled in the Quake this Grand Mosque
and Caravan Mirage is at least 580 years
old built during the Ottoman Empire it
was severely damaged more than 160
kilometers from the epicenter the new
mosque in malatya collapsed it has stood
for over 100 years and in Northern Syria
the ancient Citadel in Aleppo a UNESCO
world heritage site already ravaged by a
decade of war was damaged even further
earthquakes are a force of nature they
can't be stopped but it is how we
respond that can restore our faith in
humanity countries from around the world
are sending money and people to the
region setting aside their differences
to do so and that desire to help a
country in need is one bright spot in
this Bleak disaster as Eric Sorensen
explains
they are inconsolable and there is
nothing that can make it better when
lives are lost
but there are injured and lives to be
saved even amid the suffering and loss
and intrinsic human instinct takes over
to help pulling Rubble by hand piece by
piece the breathtaking moment when a
life emerges from the ruins
and from the hopelessness
with a kiss and a smile
we will stay here until we take them out
he says turkey historically a bridge to
the world straddles both Europe and Asia
and now the world is responding dozens
of countries growing almost by the hour
have promised money machinery and
Manpower even dogs Stefan Hines with his
rescue dog minks there is always a
miracle in such an earthquake he says we
will do our best from flattened
neighborhoods to Fallen villages in the
Mountain snow help is needed I haven't
seen anything like this before that you
have an area which is 100 kilometers
long where every village every town is
affected and in turkey and Syria help is
welcomed five thousand people is coming
from the other country therefore we need
you all help we need your people power
Russia has sent a search and rescue team
for some a contradiction for the
unnatural disaster it has brought to
Ukraine but in this case they have
common cause Ukraine is also sending Aid
to Turkey and while many countries would
normally not help the brutal regime in
Syria a humanitarian crisis changes the
calculation please don't politicize any
of this let's get
the the aid out to to the people who who
so desperately need it and so from China
comes a rescue team from Mexico Red
Cross Personnel from India medical
supplies from Pakistan a team chanting
we are Rescuers
even Greece is sending help to its
bitter rival turkey we live in a world
with in which at the end of the day we
are dependent upon one another and we
need to help one another and that is a
silver lining and and not an unimportant
one
late at night a middle-aged woman is
pulled out alive in kirkhan local and
international Rescuers hug one another
but just for a moment there are more
lives to save
Eric Sorensen Global News
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is the CN Tower in Toronto which
went dark overnight for five minutes
each hour in honor of the victims of the
earthquakes in turkey and Syria
thanks for watching bye-bye
[Music]